OK ! 1,2,1,2,1,2 ! OK on y va !
Bonsoir à tous !
pardon les oreilles comment allez-vous les amis moi ça va extrêmement bien et ça va encore mieux que d'habitude parce qu'aujourd'hui on va tourner
une vidéo avec Natsu
qui à chaque fois m'regarde comme ça avant chaque début de vidéo et je me sens mal je culpabilise et si j'ai arrêté de travailler
et de faire ce que j'aime pour dédier ma vie à mon chien je me suis déjà posé cette question je vais pas vous mentir
depuis j'ai un chien je squatte un petit peu sur net les articles qui parlent de chiens j'en ai trouvé un qui parle de tester
l'intelligence de son chien alors faut pas déconner c'est un truc pas du tout officiel et tout mais cela n'empêche que ça va quand même
tester un petit peu la jugeote de ton chien si je peux me permettre
comme vous pouvez le voir il est carrément opérationnel.. Mais, t'es même pas dans le champ, t'es même pas dans le champ !
Incroyable ça ! et je me suis dit que je
devais faire ce test pour la simple et bonne raison que je mets mon chien sur un pied d'estal de malade
un peu comme un couple qui a bébé moche mais qui le trouve beau quand même j'ai ce même manque d'objectivité vis-à-vis de mon chien je
le trouve vraiment incroyable très intelligent il est
particulier il n'est pas comme les autres chiens
mais tous les mecs qu'ont un chien dit ça je me suis donc dit Lucas, franchement faut que t'arrête de te voiler la face fait un vrai test
pour voir si ton chien est vraiment celui que tu penses alors c'est parti
c'est très simple il ya plusieurs épreuves et selon le temps que va mettre ton chien à résoudre l'énigme
il va gagner plus ou moins de points. Comment tester
l'intelligence d'un chien dans le domaine de la recherche sur l'intelligence animale la seule définition du sujet d'étude peut déjà être
difficile bien des questions de base restent sans réponse et on se querelle
indéfiniment sur la signification des résultats des tests vous pouvez donc toujours affirmer que votre chien est le plus intelligent du monde même si ses notes
sont assez médiocres. Aah ! T'entend ?
Ca veut dire on peut le faire easy mec et ça changera pas ce que je pense de toi
ces derniers sont destinés à mesurer la capacité à résoudre des problèmes et l'adaptation à l'environnement. Alors. Pf, c'est hyper violent : jetez une serviette sur la
tête du chien
Ooh mec ça me fait mal au coeur ! jetez là sur la tête du chien pour la recouvrir complètement mettez le chronomètre en route et
voyez combien de temps il faut un chien pour s'en libérer 30 secondes ou moins trois points
trente-et-une à 120 secondes deux points ils essayent mais n'y arrive pas dans les 120 premières secondes un point mais à comment il peut ne
pas réussir à se débarrasser d'une serviette, c'est..
c'est pas dur il ne cherche pas à se libérer zéro point.  c'est génial le iench jeu ça le dérange pas du tout qu'il
y est une serviette sur sa tête ! "DÉBUT DE LA PREMIERE ÉPREUVE !" voici une serviette qui possède un très joli motif. Tu t'assois ?
Ouiii c'est bien bravo mon
bébé ! M'en veut pas pense que je vais te faire c'est pour montrer au monde que tu es très intelligent. T'es près mon chien ?
Bouuum il est hyper intelligent !! Bravo, bravo, c'est bieeen !
Bravo c'est de la merde comme test hein bah oui tu es bien au dessus de ça toi tu peux résoudre des équations
toi je suis pas gaga.  c'est donc un trois points pour Natsu le Shiba Inu en fait ce test là est tellement easy à mes
yeux que ça m'aurait fait mal au coeur qu'il comprenne pas qu'il doit se débarrasser de la serviette deuxièmement cacher une friandise sous la serviette
alors vu que moi je donne pas du tout de friandises à Natsu je vais mettre une croquette sous la serviette voilà en
plus c'est cool parce que les Shiba sont des chiens très intelligents et primitifs donc en fait ça va le stimuler de devoir faire un
effort pour pouvoir manger j'ai déjà fait des tests et quand je stimule un peu
avant qu'il mange il adore ça en fait il a l'impression de mériter son repas mettez le chronomètre en route et voyez combien de temps le chien
met pour prendre la friandise ! 30 secondes ou moins 3 points, 31 à 60 secondes 2 points, essaye mais n'y arrive pas en espace de
60 secondes un point ils n'essayent pas zéro point. Mon petit Shiba Inu, vient ! Attends..
Vas-y. Prend-là ! Prends la croquette elle est dessous ! Prend la croquette elle est là ! Là dessous ! Et non pas Natte-Su!
allez vas-y, t'es intelligent ! Tiens attends, je décale tout je te le refait là !
elle est là, elle est là. mais qu'est ce qui te prend !?
Hop j'la cache !
Mais non mais elle est pas partie là, elle est là ! elle est juste là, là-dessous là
mon fils t'es intelligent, montre leurs !
Tu peux le faire mec, steuplait ne me déçoit pas mon fils tu es magnifique je sais que tu es, tu es intelligent. T'a clairement vu qu'elle
était là mais j'ai l'impression que tu as juste pas envie de bouffer une croquette
Mon chien est bêête !
C'est vraiment qu'il a même pas l'intelligence parce que la croquette l'intéressait ! oh non on est donc sur du zéro point
4ème épreuve pour ce test vous avez besoin d'une ouverture près du sol que le chien peut atteindre avec ses pattes mais non pas son
museau un
canapé peut faire l'affaire mais vous pouvez aussi en fabriquer une vous même à l'aide de deux livres et une large planche c'est vrai que
tout le monde chez soi possède une large planche alors commençons par construire cet outil du démon bouge pas mon grand
j'ai dit bouge pas putain je sais je sais je sais je critique pas je sais Natsu tu demandes ce que c'est mais le
paravent Bouddha va enfin nous servir c'est une triste fin pour mes mangas Naruto
Ok on est prêt pour le test suivant attend qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire ? Posez une friandise une planche ou un coussin du canapé pendant qu'il vous observe
s'il réussit en l'espace de deux minutes en se servant de ses pattes c'est quatre points en trois minutes
en servant de ses pattes trois points s'il a échoué deux points et s'il se sert uniquement de son museau un point. Oh la pression
j'ai la pression. ok c'est parti la friandise et sous la planche mon grand. Vas-y je l'ai mis dessous à l'instant tu l'as vue elle est là
Vous voulez que je vous dise je pense avoir compris un truc ce tapis est
dégueulasse et je pense que ça le stress de ouf
c'est la pire excuse ! Voilà ! Natsu je t'ai trouvé une excuse la prochaine fois faut que t'y arrive sinon on est mort
ok
ici elle est dessous, dessous mon grand elle est là dessous regarde va prendre la croquette mon grand ! Mange ! La croquette !
*Infraction*
*Squeezie est choqué*
mais c'est une infraction dis donc tu la veux tu va la chercher
Ok bouge pas
allez vas-y vas la prendre ici elle est là vas-y prend là, elle est là mon bébé vas-y
Bah non elle est pas là ooh ça me brise le coeur
tu préfères lécher des poussières de croquettes que de faire l'effort d'aller prendre la vraie croquettes putain t'es comme ton maître !
Vas-y prend-là, prend-là mon bébé
ça nous fait qu'un point, petit con, bravooo !
bon le paravent, on se revoit dans un an, Naruto je suis désolé, mais Boruto t'as un peu détrôné on va pas se mentir !
Ok il est temps de passer à l'épreuve suivante mon chien le test suivant est conçu pour éprouver la mémoire du chien et non pas
ses talents pour résoudre un problème dans mon cas aucun problème on a vu qu'il est balèze
pour ce faire le chien doit comprendre ce qui se passe mettez une friandise sous une coupelle en plastique et dites lui
de la trouvais ok alors ceci est une friandise ceci est un gobelet. Alors la croquette elle est où elle est où .
Elle est où la croquette ?
Il va faire toute la longueur comme ça
Mais, mec on va te retrouver dans le bureau de MacFly et Carlito ! ça suffit !
Non mais oublies ça, oublies ça. Elle est où la croquette ?
Il s'en branle !
Ok bravo !
bravo là il a compris que quand il se dirige vers le gobelet qui contient la croquette je soulève le gobelet et il peut manger
la croquette là c'est pas un test d'intelligence c'est juste pour qu'il comprenne ce qu'on attend de lui maintenant vient le vrai test posez trois
coupelles en plastique à l'envers et au sol et espacées d'environ 30 centimètres mettez une friandise sous l'une d'elles pendant que le chien vous observe
faites sortir le chien de la pièce pendant trente secondes puis revenez demande aux chiens trouver la friandise ça c'est génial
un deux trois. Je met la friandise ici
maintenant on sort on revient dans 30 secondes !
T'es prêt mon chien tu réussi l'épreuve ok go ! On y va ! alors où est la friandise, où est la friandise ? Ouiiiii bravo
J'suis émuuu !
*imitation de la mort*
Ah le batard il s'en battait les couilles, il a juste vu ça il s'est dit putain il est mort je peux y accéder
on va donc calculer notre score : on a donc eu trois points la serviette
0 point la croquette sous la serviette un point à la serviette sous l'obstacle et 2 points au jeu des
coupelles on est donc un total de six points ce qui nous donne un médor lambda
Eh ton test c'est de la grosse merde fils de p*** !
Merci d'avoir regardé cette vidéo c'était un très bon moment en votre compagnie
j'ai l'ai très à l'aise dans cette position n'est ce pas ? ça m'a fait trop plaisir de faire une vidéo avec Natsu où
j'interagis un peu avec lui
en fait dès que je tourne il est tout le temps là à côté me regarder ça me fait un peu de la peine  tu sais
c'est un Shiba c'est un chien qui a besoin d'être beaucoup stimulé et ne serait-ce que tourner deux heures être à côté de lui des
fois j'entends couiner, ça me brise le coeur donc je suis très content d'avoir pu faire ça avec lui
n'hésitez pas si vous avez un animal à jouer avec lui de cette manière là, essayer de le stimuler
intellectuellement ! je sais que pour les chats il ya des jeux aussi
intellectuels où tu met les croquettes à certains endroits ils doivent comprendre comment choper la croquette ! j'l'ai fait avec Jumbo ils s'en battaient les couilles
il a perdu 1 kilo
mais c'est cool c'est cool de travailler avec eux de cette manière là donc voilà j'suis très content et ça m'a donné envie de faire plus
souvent vraiment aller au maximum de bisous à vous et à vos animaux
ou à vos parents que si vous n'avez pas d'animaux a très vite dans une prochaine vidéo portez vous bien et le Natsu s'endort regardez
ce qui veut dire que ces petites épreuves l'ont vraiment stimulé, il est fatigué carrément bon allez, salut, je pourrais vous parler de
Natsu pendant huit mois vu que c'est toute ma vie maintenant mais il faut mettre fin cette vidéo aller
Merci à HALEGARD,Aurore,mariecurry azeb et
Black James & Gamz_Neo YT pour ces sous titres ;)